sujet particulier mais qui me passionne
depuis plusieurs mois le cas du grand
amiral thrawn on a eu le temps de
caresser son existence dans le trois
théories sur mandat lauriane que je vous
invite à avoir au revoir d'ailleurs mais
il est temps de plonger en détails sur
le personnage car l'intégration de
thrawn dans la trame live axsun donc
avec des acteurs tous à des films star
wars ou série ma ce n'est plus qu'une
question de temps avant ça évidemment
j'aimerais vous rappeler que vous êtes
très nombreux à regarder la chaîne sans
être abonné n'hésitez surtout pas à le
faire avec l'arrivée du grand nombre de
projets star wars là dans les années à
venir et où il va y avoir du contenu et
franchement il ya de belles choses à
dire vous pouvez compter sur moi bref
tout d'abord remettons les choses dans
leur contexte
2012 c'est le rachat de lucasfilm par
disney et donc par extension de la saga
star wars
ce rachat amènera une nouvelle politique
en 2014 qui définit que toutes les
oeuvres secondaire catégorisé comme
l'univers étendu basse et plus
officielle donc à l'exception des deux
trilogies d'origine ainsi que le dessin
animée clone wars
tout le contenu star wars sorti avant
2014 a été balayée pour être défini
comme les djeun's soit d'une
un officiel c'est très important de le
rappeler car cela démontre clairement la
vision de disney avec ce rachat de star
wars
ils veulent proposer de l'inédit et
c'est quelque chose qu'on va retrouver
notamment chez notre sujet du jour le
grand amiral thrawn c'est donc
officiellement par le biais du nouveau
canon que thrones sera introduit dans la
saison 3 de star wars rebels comme
l'ennemi ultime des rebelles et c'est là
que le mystère commence certainement
l'une des plus grande porte restait
ouverte la fin de rebels nous propose
une ultime bataille entre le jeune jedi
ezra bridgeurs et le grand amiral thrawn
par le biais d orgue hills des créatures
capables de voyager en hyperespace izraa
pour idée d'exil et thrones et ses
forces le plus loin possible pour les
empêcher de nuire à la rébellion une
bonne fois pour toute et redonner
l'espoir un acte noble
mais qui conduira à la fois ezra et
thrones dans un horizon totalement
inconnu de tous et avec un vaisseau
endommagé qui souligne l'idée d'un acte
de non retour et la solitude des
protagonistes pour se sortir de tout ça
et pour confirmer ses conséquences la
scène de fin de rebels nous montrera le
retour d'ahsoka vers sabine pour partir
à la recherche des draps une scène qui
encore aujourd'hui n'est pas
chronologiquement installés notamment à
cause de la saison de deux mandats
lauriane concernant mandaloriennes la
série introduit à saucats en live action
pour la première fois situé 25 ans avant
le réveil de la force mentale oriane
nous montre une asso cas toujours en
quête des draps bridgeurs toujours
portées disparues c'est à la fin de son
épisode dédié que l'information sera
révélé sur sa quête
suite à sa victoire face à morgane
health bête une adepte de l' empire et
de la marine impériale dans ses plus
jeunes années et ayant très certainement
servi pour ce trône à saucats tentera de
lui soutirer des informations sur la
localisation de thrawn car s'ils en
trouvent thrones
on trouvait sera
logiquement mais qu'en est il réellement
c'est ça le coeur de la vidéo où s rhône
et comment l'intégrer dans la section
live action de star wars
alors il faut être clair il est
impossible de savoir exactement où s
rhône surtout à l'heure actuelle des
années après l'action des saints
rien ne nous dit qu'il n'a pas bougé
depuis toutes ces années en fait ou
qu'il est toujours en compagnie des sera
par exemple mais en fonction de récents
comics ou encore les dernières oeuvres
il y a moyen de suspects et quand même
certaines choses tron est un seigneur de
la guerre et un analyste
hors pair qui a gravi les échelons pour
ces masters classes dans l' empire
sauf que c'est difficile de le réduire
qu'à ça ce drone est un personnage calme
précis et c'est un perfectionniste
rien n'est laissé au hasard chez ce
dernier qui est très réputé pour ses
anticipations des attaques ennemies ou
encore le fait d'apprendre et connaître
la culture son ennemi pour mieux le
comprendre et le vaincre beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent bien évidemment
déjà thrones mais c'est important de
bien le définir pour ce qu'il découvre
bref toute cette personnalité est
accentuée notamment avec le comics star
wars throne le protégé de l'empereur qui
dévoile de nombreux éléments
intéressants thrones n'a rien à faire de
l' empire depuis le début ce n'est qu'un
outil pour à la fois protéger son peuple
natale des menaces externes comme l'
empire par exemple genre autant se faire
un puissant allié qu'un puissante et non
le coeur et les objectifs de ce trône ne
vont pas à l' empire en priorité mais à
l'ascension chis sa terre et son peuple
natale et c'est une chose que même
l'empereur n'aura pas décelé durant
toute sa carrière
c'est seulement à la guerre de l'eau
talent que palpatine a souhaité discuter
avec thrones sauf qu'évidemment il a
disparu avec ezra à ce moment là donc
voilà rien qu'avec ça thrones même si
a énormément marqué lempire est
également les débuts du premier ordre
eh bien il n'a plus rien à voir avec ça
aujourd'hui c'est du passé
petite précision pour certains mais si
je dis que ce rôle a marqué les débuts
du premier ordre
c'est que vu que ce trône est originaire
de la bordure extérieure des régions
inconnues et caetera et bien ses
connaissances et son savoir ont
énormément servi pour l'ascension du
premier ordre dans l'ombre
voilà ils se sont développés dans les
régions inconnues grâce au savoir de
throne bref fin de la parenthèse est
justement deuxième point là-dessus la
bordure extérieure et les terres
inconnues le savoir concernant tout ça
que possède ce drone est énorme
étant originaire d'un peuple prévoyant
contre les attaques des autres et les
menaces grondante thrones a exploré la
bordure extérieure de nombreuses
reprises voir la cartographier alors oui
l'espace est réputé pour être infinie
mais bon on reste quand même dans du
star wars par le biais d'une petite
facilités scénaristiques et tout le
savoir que possède ce trône ce dernier a
de grandes chances de savoir à peu près
où il a atterri après l'action d'ezra et
maintenant je dois vous parler de
l'ascendance chis et plus
particulièrement des lits 22 ans et liv
en taux était en quelque sorte le
protégé de thrawn durant son ascension
dans l' empire
au départ simple inventoriste et
traducteur du cheese thrones à la fin de
sa carrière lui fera connaissance de ses
véritables intentions et lui permettra
de participer à l'ascendance chis chose
qu'il acceptera en quittant lempire pour
rejoindre les rangs chis et c'est une
section très importante a souligné
qu'aar elie vento n'est pas le premier
personnage acquis thrones a proposé
cette opportunité ce qui signifie
clairement qu'il peut exister d'autres
protagonistes qui ont rejoint les rangs
cheese par le biais de
ce trône je pense par exemple à morgane
health bête l'antagoniste du chapitre
xiii demande à laurianne une ex marine
impériale qui assoit son règne sur une
petite planète dans les régions
inconnues
après sa défaite à saucats lui demandera
où se trouve son maître en parlant de ce
trône déjà on ne parle pas d'anciens m
ahsoka parle bien de son maître actuel
donc est ce que cela pourrait signifier
que ce trône est revenu parmi les
chiffres étant un peuple qui se définit
comme ascendant l'ascendance chis bas on
parle d'un peuple qui évidemment à des
conquêtes a de l'ambition
bref qui veut grimper on va dire et
c'est dans cette raison que thrones a
invité de rares personnes à rejoindre sa
patrie dans une optique du retour de
tron dans son peuple à guider les
personnes qui l'a amené dans sa patrie
morgan health bête pourrait asseoir à un
règne pour l'ascendance chis ce qui
expliquerait pourquoi thrones est son
maître pour revenir à elie vento qui est
très liée à thrones sans oublier le
peuple chis le grand amiral ne laisse
absolument rien au hasard comme je vous
le disais l'événement provoquant sa
disparition a dû se faire savoir parmi
ses alliés qui sont très certainement
partie à sa recherche par rapport à son
intégration dans les oeuvres live action
de la firme
je vois mal la saison 3 de the
mandaloriennes se tourner dans cette
direction je vous invite à voir mon
trois théories évidemment sur la saison
de demande alors ya la saison 3 mais la
recherche de throne et des draps semble
être plutôt le sujet de la série dédiée
à ahsoka ahsoka qui en tant qu'ex jedi
n'a plus de raisons d'agir sauf pour
payer sa dette
entre guillemets envers israël qui l'a
sauvé d'une mort certaine
tronet sera étant des éléments
scénaristiques important et intéressant
pour l'avenir de la saga sont forcément
vivent quelque part dans l'univers
sachant que thrones est 100% tourner
vers le cheese il n'a aucune raison de
s'entretuer avec ezra après leur voyage
en hyperespace au contraire israël loin
d'être une menace pour ce trône est
temps liée à l' empire thrones se devait
donc d'affronter aux rats et j'irai même
peut-être plus loin en affirmant que ce
tron s'est laissé avoir par ezra pour
justement éviter l'interrogatoire de
l'empereur sur ses véritables intentions
mais bon ça reste une très grosse
suppositions dans tous les cas le seul
défaut véritable de ce trône et sa
méconnaissance de la force comme le
démontre et star wars rebels en
cohabitant de force avec israël ce
dernier aura certainement pu en
comprendre davantage ce sera intéressant
en tout cas de voir le décalage entre la
mission d'ahsoka qui souhaitera très
certainement défis et thrones et le
vaincre alors que ce dernier sera
finalement passer à autre chose
bien des années plus tôt car au vu des
convictions des draps et de thrawn bas
ce serait étonnant que les personnages
aient collaboré longtemps ensemble
mais qu'en est il des sera justement eh
bien vous de me dire ce sujet mérite
audience pour une vidéo dédiée
j'attends vos commentaires et vos avis
bien évidemment comme toujours je vous
propose ma vision 100% personnelle et
subjective
il est possible que tout ce que je vous
raconte tout ce que je vous dis là ça
n'arrivera absolument jamais mais je
trouve quand même que la question est
hyper intéressante a souligné à répondre
il peut vraiment y avoir du débat
intéressant donc voilà j'attends comme
je disais j'attends vos avis n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à la chaîne a laissé
un petit pouce bleus si la vidéo vous a
plu
et puis voilà écouter cet argot rock et
que le lionheart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]